manda me machucar mas portugal tem 20
anos de estudo foi caótica no segundo
ano o custo normal para a espanha mas
tenho epilepsia não faltou se vão e
neste momento sofro de depressão
profunda
sim a mãe de família e quando estava a
subir ao palco
eu andava através do do tópico desta
troca e inconformismo por isso eu
lembrei que tinha um texto preparado mas
acho que hoje é uma desculpa para nós
não seguimos as regras por isso tem que
preparar o responsável por exemplo estou
no terceiro a opção fundão e epilepsia
vamos contar isto dentro de 15 minutos
e ao contrário do que é mostrado o santa
cruz não tem que pagar até o dia 15 de
abril para saber o final
por isso é que eu vou começar de 2014
2014 a e escrita em inglês e assim ajude
a mudar seu primeiro ano como é que isso
aconteceu aconteceu
simplesmente porque eu estava
completamente nervoso por um texto e não
tinha juízo a troca dos anos e quando
ganhou mais nada essa mãe brasileira uma
cor comportamento tecidos ou seja é
única memória de ver a cara dos meus
amigos simplesmente julgarem e uma o
corpo como a conclusão das aulas
simplesmente por que não criam lidará
com o contato pessoal físico mas agora
deve estar a pensar eu quero conquistar
este jovem de 20 anos a fazer aqui é um
psicólogo nenhum
psiquiatra neurologista e com corpos
certa forma ou seja também fiquei a
pensar olha aí o que que eu vou o que eu
vou fazer o toque é falar de estigmas de
pressão que as doenças mentais
comecei a pensar o campo posso falar da
vida equilibrada com o time até agora e
explicar aquilo que eu usei para evitar
voltar contra crimes e que é melhor
falar de mim não é importante disputar
neste dia com um desperdício de vidas 24
horas 2014
eu como já disse a partir desse momento
não quis voltar mas alguns ficam
animassem nas aulas e só as aulas
importantes que eu estava mais
importante é fazer os testes só exames
mesmo assim nosso bairro mas como podem
concluir a minha média desceu
drasticamente o quadro vamos fazer mais
por ano mesmo assim tenta ter uma vida
mais regular possível fazer de porto
mauá café com os amigos
o estudo surge com estudo começou a
surgir sete pontos
ou seja falta de autoestima uma tristeza
muito prolongado
parecia que o viomundo tozzo com uma
saturação muito baixa para 5 mundo
estava tudo preto e branco discurso de
repente apareceram como podem ver a
imagem
não foi por acaso que eu tire o preto e
branco é maior para as coxas seja os
altos e baixos mas também profunda que
está acontecendo eu fui descobrindo ao
longo do tempo num carro pra frente eu
numa nota no final sendo um do outro
outros dos padrões que eu já não tinha
são trocados com garra e quando de
tristeza prolongava não em três dias é
mais duas semanas e meses é e parece que
eu era simplesmente uma lente que estava
a tentar ficar um objetivo mas
simplesmente não queria ficar
mesmo assim eu como diz são socorros
lutar contra quando logo eu tive um
preto quatro anos
a opção é tentar o atacante como já está
fazendo o que fazemos porto tentando o
parma e nos ajudar com amigos em do modo
perfeito com amigos
mesmo assim tentar entrar em uma praça
na empresa minha faculdade e mesmo assim
em um canto bem não tinha problemas em
amigos e netos é prioritário e foi
exatamente isto que eu consegue usar
todo o processo que eu tenho isso porque
conquistaram fãs e outros quatro anos eu
escrevi cerca de quatro horas desde o
processo de 2014
até a música do ano procurando atacar
conta que foi o que julgava que falhou
por eu estar assim porque é como estar
social porque estou zangado com o
próprio depois consegue analisar eo está
aqui qualquer coisa mal eu vou parar de
fingir que só o solitário no mercosul
assim tão forte porque muitas vezes nós
capazes e especialmente que nós a passo
temos a obsessão que o homem não chora
não é o homem tem que ser forte em que
só vê sozinho não é simplesmente pensar
em outubro 2018 está na altura de pedir
ajuda e vamos direcionar não ficou
não há stress vou tentar perceber o que
está a acontecer comigo e para perceber
bem como aprimorar não foi covarde foi
desde cedo foi conseguido no secundário
para estudar para lisboa durante um mês
a perceber que eu estava maluco estava
mal e jogou à vontade para vencer o 2º
trânsito uma semana está matemática
durante uma semana porque é e eles para
falar de economia na terceira fase os
pequenos bastante a cabeça mas já tinha
já 18 minutos e 33 de cabeça
isso é normal portanto uma frase ao
contrário do andré é uma fase muito
inspiradora tua conta é muito inspirador
mas eu antes
bruxelas fica numa fase que é esta
vão cansar o chinês dos anos 400 cristo
que é o confúcio que estávamos mais
fashions aula
aumentamos nossa chapa é porque não tem
mais nada a perder por isso que nós
vamos ganhar
e foi aí que eu decidi então procurar um
psicólogo ou seja uma ajuda e também
aprende maps que eles chamam de
psicoterapia chamas a sair muito antes
dos 60 gente possa assim seja com isto o
que acredito que esse processo é
basicamente simula a nós a nossa faz
rimas ela é rápida em movimento quando
estamos em primeiro e assim nós
conseguimos estimular todos os nossos
móveis mais e que dá importância à
cerimônia
além disso também faz a canon o que eu
achava mais comuns nesses dias a chuva
uma opção
muitas vezes as palavras magoou mais do
que as ações não foi por acaso que eu
queria que tivesse a cara de cansaço
portanto o momento que eu acho que eu
achei que era muito comum nesse lado era
as pessoas descobrirem nós temos mais
pressão e de repente três provas assim
não sei por que é que estás premissa
triste tudo está feliz quando é pra mim
quando será a apresentação estava na
direção da constelação de janeiro
empresas portuguesas e tem é meu cargo
a parceria em nível internacional e ii
nacional eu andando deverá viajar pela
europa porque ele estava e fui eu não
tenho casa apartamento foi isso
isso chama momento de cair é uma mechas
basicamente isso o brasil fica tensa
como própria porque não havia razão
mesmo período também foi agindo assim o
nosso corpo diz que nós temos e foi isso
porque o nosso corpo neste momento está
em falta de dopamina e serotonina
o momento que eu achei que realmente
acho que o aumento da ignorância
resposta ignorante é são as pessoas que
viram se para nós e dizem eu também já
tive uma depressão eu pois para pensar
nisso e pessoa possa já esta resposta é
a primeira vez que fizeram isto é
simplesmente dizer isto eu para dizer
uma pessoa que tem um cancro de pulmão
por exemplo o anel cozinha no campo que
ok eu tenho um carro eu parei de pensar
no campo é onde eu estava
a gente imagina que deixar as últimas
hoje fazendo centenas de amigos mais a
nossa vida miltão que nós temos feito
tudo fizemos para mim funcionou
perfeitamente
certamente está com nenhuma concretude e
sentar na varanda e assim se eu quiser
falar da opção eu falo simplesmente
serve às vezes só com a presença de
amigos e assim não saber quando é que
gire e como temos que agir da maneira
como nós pensamos como devemos lidar
portanto o que nós temos aqui o que tira
em todo este processo criativo fazer
ignorante claro muito
então nós estamos no aviso do que eu
precisava então não terá que abrir uma
terceira um ano porque o momento que eu
diz causa uma nova amiga hora porque
porque existe o cinco nacional e como já
disseram tudo porque assim
mas nossos amigos dizem se não tivesse a
mesma nota se não tivesse emprego não é
ninguém na vida não é fácil que eu
quiser porque o crítico joão fontes isso
aí que eu vou dizer porque existe um
sistema na sociedade entre a humildade
ea falsa modéstia
isto é responsável por mais e portanto e
foi aqui que eu comecei a perceber a
atenção entre as duas é por isso que eu
passo para minha história aqui parece
que não que não doeu muito porque estou
a dizer isto que conseguir isso só com
uma cara mais ou menos normal o
movimento que este processo difícil mas
como muitas pessoas tenham e que não
quiseram dizer cá para fora
eu sei que existe a história até agora é
por isso que esta pode estar em branco e
preto
mas eu agradeço muito a vossa presença
por estar aqui e espero que daqui pra
frente você escrever este livro também
conversar processo e como disse
a partir deste momento que eu consiga
extinguir que era um novato falsa
modéstia e consegui finalmente quinzena
eu mereço e vocês conhecem toda está
aqui nós relativamente como se dava a
gente não quer
digamos que são bons porque prestamos a
vangloriar ou porque somos a voz entre
que não é simplesmente ignorante nós
somos nós porque somos nós e por isso
conclui assim espero que tenham gostado
[Aplausos]